how's go Braz minutes for that this
godforsaken game I played a lot of these
rage games
I never struggled so much as this
[ __ ] ghost part I hate it I hate it
so much to ease the pain
we're gonna do this I don't normally do
this but just to make it easier this is
a piss from homeless person living
outside but it shows how beats playing
this now in comparison if game is
fantastic likes donates [ __ ] yo I hate
this part
alright I've done this part like I'm I
like I wouldn't say a million but I
don't want to brag or anything you know
these these videos that I make and like
there H ones these are the type of
videos I don't want if I ever have kids
don't watch this video
okay oh [ __ ] yes alright here's the
tricky part
it's a tricky part you don't know if
he's gonna jump or not how am I supposed
to know every time I have to wait for
the [ __ ] clown i loose like 1 year of
my life span all right I don't know
what's up with this part
[ __ ] you all right we did it oh god it's
acting me I need some of that this maybe
they even UPS my skills a little bit
let's find out okay
alright we're into banana part we're at
the banana point I repeat the banana
part it's upon us we will do it we shall
the way go up it's completely random
been in this game will be like murdery
Hitler it won't be like a making out
with Martha Stewart
it would be like slapping Ellen
DeGeneres on the ass that's how I would
describe the sensation Oh God
i i'm not i'm not even pissed anyway
like butthole fighter would he leave
that jab that way get hella bang they're
pissed
just give me the piss alright mmm-hmm
this isn't give me [ __ ] going on the
toilet gives me more [ __ ] than base I
don't what am I supposed to do if he
attacks me right what okay okay this is
our moment this is our break up like
sucking on it well I guess not Rebecca I
will complete this [ __ ] mother
[ __ ] you stop killing me before I am
there now am i fine fine that's pretty
gross don't kill me right away that'd be
great yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] you and you
[ __ ] me so many times
the pee is not helping my skills
please do kill me before I even get a
[ __ ] chance to [ __ ] about Adam well I
never hated bananas send it this much to
me forward oh god oh god oh god
did you see that [ __ ] now I'm gonna do
it then get [ __ ] do it me ah oh [ __ ]
my ass out you can do this you
[ __ ] [ __ ] Oh Mike holy and oh
how did I end up here my job was to play
video games
what the [ __ ] I'm not stopping today
until I have defeated the giant ghost of
unjust and suffering see what am I
supposed to do this game is like running
a marathon
Oh what the [ __ ] was that this game is
like running a marathon with your eyes
I hate everything
oh my god why me
what's up Baima boy am I done
can you [ __ ] me my truck please every
day that doesn't make me gay please come
on over here and [ __ ] me and my duck you
thought it was going up down come up
here and [ __ ] me like a man
no wait yeah okay yeah that's fair fair
fair chance
Oh job Larry get skills metal tone and
burn on feet done done
you taught him I don't fit Donna's
children don't shut up that it up before
he beat that
oh hi dude I'm making it so much harder
for myself oh god oh god oh god
take that damn but take the
[ __ ] ass licking [ __ ]
banana oh god yeah alright I'm dead now
funk it's like it's completely [ __ ]
right I'm if you jump up on the [ __ ]
block or not I died 244 times 245 oh my
god I got it it's taking me so long can
I jump over him anyway why so many
motions that was all I had to do are you
serious [ __ ] this